today I'm campaign check the
conservative manifesto and the Tories
say they want to focus on areas like NHS
schools tackling crime while also
cutting taxes for millions of workers
sounds big doesn't it but how do their
spending plans compare with other
parties let's have a look at what
they're adding to current spending so
day to day expenditure on salaries
welfare stuff like that just under 3
billion pounds a year by 2023 224 now
let's compare that with the Lib Dems
will be spending nearly 50 billion
pounds a year extra by then and labour
want to increase spending by an annual
eighty three billion pounds over the
same period now in case you're wondering
these really are like four like figures
for every pound extra pound the Tories
spend running the government labour are
planning to spend twenty eight pounds
it's an astounding gap and it means that
those Tory giveaways are actually quite
small though they do come on top of the
money in this year's spending around so
there's an extra 1.7 billion pounds a
year that goes on health so more nurses
GP appointments free Hospital parking
stuff like that but it's worth saying
the Tories are also planning to cut
taxes too so you can see here about 3.6
billion pounds a year money coming out
of the Treasury on top of the spending
increases when it comes in this bar here
now most of this is the increase in
national insurance thresholds to 9,500
pounds that costs two and a half billion
pounds as you can see here but didn't
mr. Johnson promise to increase it to
12,500 pounds well yes he did but it
isn't in the manifesto why mainly
because getting there would be very very
expensive indeed about four times the
money budgeted here so there were a few
other changes but in the grand scheme of
things the numbers here are all pretty
small and this money needs to be
financed so how are the Tories actually
doing that
short answer mainly by cancelling their
corporation tax cut that saves a
whopping 6.3 billion pounds a year they
say now all of that is current spending
what about capital spending so big
investments in roads rails stuff like
that here there's much less difference
the Tories want to invest up to a
hundred billion pounds over the next
five years but they've only laid out
about 22 billion of that in detail in
comparison labour is pledging to invest
400 billion pounds through two new funds
though parts of that are going to be
spent
years so over five years is probably
around 275 billion pounds the lib dems
on the other hand they want to invest a
hundred and thirty billion pounds the
majority of that is going to be spent
tackling climate change so all of the
parties all the major parties want to
spend much more on investment but
there's a big difference when it comes
to day-to-day spending and the upshot is
in many senses the Tory manifesto it's
actually quite cautious cautious in
spending cautious - about the policies
so gone are there controversial things
for the 2017 manifesto the dementia tax
that some say flauta resume is it too
cautious to win over voters or on the
other hand will they respond positively
to this comparative fiscal restraint